(digital noise swooshes)
- On this episode, Eugene Remm stops by
and talks entrepreneurship, Catch, Rumble,
and we had a couple of calls
that were fucking legit!
(upbeat horns and percussion music)
Hey everybody this is Gary Vaynorchuk,
Episode 303 of the Ask Gary Vee show!
(bell dings)
I'm excited, you can tell by my energy,
couple things that are exciting me, one,
a couple of my favorite alumni
are back in the building,
'cause two very handsome men
work for another handsome
man and he's here.
Eugene, I'm gonna allow
you to introduce yourself
to the audience in a minute.
Amazing entrepreneur
behind some of my favorite
brands in culture right now.
Catch, Rumble and other things.
We'll get into his
origin story in a second.
Instagram and Facebook you guys are live,
but ultimately why I
think I'm most pumped is,
I just tasted Empathy
Rose for the first time.
Our master plan is in
motion, I'm very excited.
And, this should be a really good episode.
So Eugene, for the Vaynor
nation that's listening,
why don't you tell them who you are
and how you synthesize your origin story?
- How I arrived here?
- Who are you?!
- Who am I?
- Yes.
- All right well Gary thanks
for having me, appreciate it.
I've never seen such an
energetic group of people
in an office before.
(Gary laughs)
This is crazy.
- [Gary] Thank you.
- My name is Eugene Remm.
I'm co-founder of Catch Hospitality Group,
we own Catch in New York,
Los Angeles, Los Vegas,
Playa del Carmen and Lexington Brass.
Also co-founder of Rumble Boxing.
Which is here in New York, LA, DC,
Philly and San Francisco with
a lot more coming there.
And I came here via
Russia, from New Jersey,
which I don't think would be interesting
to any of your viewers,
because they wouldn't
know what that was about.
But came to the States
in 1980 and grew up in
Bergen County, New Jersey
and worked my way to
Hofstra University and
then New York City at 22.
And started in the mail room.
- How old are you now?
- 40.
- It's really crazy how
similar our backgrounds are.
- [Gary] Yeah.
- Like really kind of scary similar.
- It is, it is.
- Like, Soviet Union,
during a, have you by the way,
did you know how few people
got out during our era?
- I do.
- I actually Googled it,
- Okay.
- during Thanksgiving with my parents.
It was in the hundreds of thousands.
- [Gary] Yeah.
- It's nuts.
- And they were all like homies, too.
They all like knew each other.
I feel like they were all
like Saint Petersburgians.
- Did you have family in America?
Your parents had to have somebody.
- We had a,
a cousin, my cousin and my
father's sister was here,
but we had to stop in Italy,
- Me too.
- for like three,
four months or something.
- Did you go in Austria
for a few weeks, too?
- No I don't think that
was, I know we were--
- That's how they changed it in '80
compared to '78.
- That's right, that's right.
I know that's how I live pizza and pasta,
because we lived right
above a pizza store.
I remember that and then we came,
I don't remember, but I'm told that,
but it's crazy man, it's crazy.
And by the way, a lot of successful people
coming out of that little, little,
little, little, sample of people.
It's pretty dope.
- It's true.
But it's also interesting,
what's interesting about you,
and I talk about it often,
and we've become friendly
in recent years and a lot of it, you know.
You know I'm super happy
to have you on the show,
- Thank you.
- because sometimes you'll
ping me randomly and be like,
"Oh I like that podcast,
"I like that podcast."
So it's super, we've become friendly.
Kids that I liked a lot
that worked at Vaynor
that like the machine was fucking up.
So I'm like hey go to him.
Like there's so much warmth in here.
- [Gary] Yeah.
- But, what's interesting
is I often say like,
I was unusual, because I
was such a bad student,
when all of our contemporaries need to be.
But like listen,
Hofstra's way better
than Mount Ida College,
but it's no fucking Yale.
- No, no, no.
- You must have been
the shit student, too.
- I was a D student, I
was a C minus student.
And by the way there's Hofstra
and then there's New School at Hofstra.
Where it's like if you can't
get in to the regular Hofstra.
- That's where you went?!
- They sent you, yup,
they send you to the New School.
I was able to get back up
to the regular Hofstra,
but let me tell you,
- It's a school!
- Smaller classes,
- It's really crazy,
- admitted at, yeah.
- like how bad of students we were.
- Yeah, because, the way people teach--
- Were you baseball carded out?
I thought we talked about this.
- I was baseball carded out,
I was flea marketed out.
My father had a stand
selling the Russian dolls,
and he gave me 20%
of his stand.
- Matryoshka fucking shit?
- And Matryoshkas and the
amber and all that crap.
He gave me 20% of his table, but for me
it was an opportunity
to hang out with my dad.
And it was an opportunity
to sell some stuff.
And it kept me busy,
'cause that was my sport.
That was my sport, so it was like,
I didn't understand what
it really all meant,
because my dad couldn't
sew it up for me together.
But now looking back on it you're like,
all right, when it was cold
and they had a snow day,
you'd go knock on doors
and you shovel snow,
because that's how you make some cash.
Money was freedom, period.
If I got money, I could do things.
If I got no money, my parents
weren't giving it to me
So that's how I connected
this whole thing.
- All the young hustlers on right now,
make sure you put your phone numbers in,
Andy K is sitting by the computer
ready to take phone numbers.
We're gonna do call in pretty soon.
So, you know,
here's where our stories deviate.
You're much cooler than me.
- Definitely not.
- Yes you definitely are.
- You definitely are.
I go liquor store, you go
into the night life scene
in New York.
- That's right, yes.
- How did that all break out?
- Real simple, moved to New York,
I was a bartender in college.
I took a crap job in ad
sales, hated my life.
And I moved to the,
the storage room at a fashion
and celebrity PR firm.
But I knew you could wear sweatpants
and I knew you could listen to Hip Hop.
(Gary laughs)
And I knew that like,
and that was really it, and I was like,
well this must be for me.
And would just walk down
the streets of New York
and be like, who is
walking around in a T shirt
and jeans at Noon?
While I'm in this crap
suit at this crap job.
And I was like, this can't be.
So, really humbling 22 Gs a year.
But I had bought some houses in college
with my bartending money,
that we started flipping,
so I had enough cash to hold me over.
And that's the money I used
so I can live in New York.
So I started going out.
I made my own business card
in a company that had no,
that wouldn't allow me to
make my business cards.
I wanted to get into the clubs.
So I started doing that, they said, "Hey,
"you can work the door
for free at our events
"on the weekends if you want."
And I was like, "Absolutely."
And they thought I was nuts.
But I wanted the access.
So I started meeting people.
And I did that for about 18
months and then 9/11 hit,
and then the PR market just dried,
because nobody wants to talk about
so and so wearing Jimmy Choo's after 9/11.
And then I took a job, I got lucky,
I got a job with Randy and Scott Gerber,
who owned the W Hotel bars,
and that was my first job.
And I did special events for them,
but they let me have a comp account.
And on the weekends I could
go to my other friends' places
and pay for shit, or I
can go to these places,
invite people and not pay for shit.
And that's how it kind of started.
So--
- That was your leverage.
- That was my leverage.
That was my equity that I had with people.
- You're young and you're contemporaries.
And you guys could, you
could in essence entertain
at nice places.
- I could entertain
at a place that didn't have
anyone else entertaining.
While my friends were working
at the coolest places,
I wouldn't say that they were the coolest
places on Earth, but they
were certainly good enough.
But the experience that I could personally
create for them, would be better.
And that's how I kind of
worked it and one by one.
And I worked for Randy
and Scott for two years.
Then a gentleman named
Steve Hanson, who's like a G
in New York and if you go--
- Star?
- No it was BR Guest.
- BR Guest.
- He sold it, but you know
he had 20 restaurants.
And I go to work for him,
I'm 25 years old now.
And I opened--
- Didn't he crush at Meat Packing?
- He was at me, he told me
what the Meat Packing was.
He said I'm opening up
- Right, I remember.
- this space in the Meat
Packing, this little V.
I took a Saturday night off,
I just walked around there
and I saw all these bars.
And then you saw some like,
you know you saw meat lockers,
then you saw trannys and drug dealers.
And you're like, well this
must be where it's at,
if you get a little bit of everything.
And, I became the director
of promotions for his company
at 25--
- And he drilled
Meat Packing, right?
- He drilled everything.
He drilled New York City.
And I never met a man who
worked as hard as he did.
He worked 22 hours a day.
He would be able to respond to my email
at the end of a 4 am shift.
And he would start those
emails at like 6:00 a.m.
and he would go.
- What's he up to these days?
- Well he sold BR Guest to Starwood
and then Starwood sold
it to my current partner.
Landry, so it's come full circle,
which is super interesting.
I think, you know he bought a hotel
and he buys a building, but
I think he's semi-retired.
- How old is he?
- Living, I think, I don't know.
I'm not sure exactly.
I think he's 60-ish.
But yeah, he was a beast.
And I got to say, we talk
about mentorship a lot,
you talk about mentorship a lot.
But I probably spend a
total of 72 hours with him
in two years, but I can
tell you those 72 hours
with that one man,
set the tone, shaped everything.
So it's not about like, oh I worked
for this guy for two years.
- So let's talk about this.
This is very meta.
There's a young man sitting
like two people behind you.
- Nice to meet you.
- Who literally call,
who literally call, talk
about meta, on meta, on meta.
Who literally called in on
an AskGaryVee type thing,
but it was just by myself.
We had this kind of like
fun moment, he was great.
And I just liked him,
and I said, "Come in."
And here he is, this
is the day he came im.
- Well, welcome!
- And I just met with him before this.
- Yeah.
- And I basically told
him to work for Dave East,
the Hip Hop artist,
- Yeah.
- for free, right?
And this is like my
biggest, like I believe
in this the most.
People are listening right now.
They're about to call in,
put in your phone number
for Eugene, we're gonna get
to your calls in a minute.
Especially the hustlers.
And what I mean by hustlers,
you've been listening,
you know my back story, you've
been listening to Eugene's.
Eugene is an, I mean this, and
we don't even know each other
well enough for me to almost
paint this compliment.
- I'll take it though,
thank you, appreciate it.
- You're gonna take it.
- Appreciate it.
- There haven't been a
lot of people I've met
in the last five years,
that there's this delta, x and y axis,
of me genuinely liking a human being,
and me believing in
their actual skill set.
You sit on a very, we've only spent 11,
six, seven hours together.
- [Eugene] Yup.
- But it's already there for me.
So here you are, you've been
successful by all accounts.
I personally believe that you're about
to get really successful.
- Thank you.
- Because I think you're
patient and hungry, and
doing the right things.
And even if the global
economy takes a step back,
I just, I can see it.
- Yes.
- I know exactly who you're
gonna be at 71, and I'm looking forward
to having more stories with you.
- Okay.
This won't be around in 71, but yes.
- But you're sitting here
and telling everybody,
the 72 hours I spent
with this person shaped,
you know had your natural DNA,
- Yeah.
- hustler and did shit fine.
I just wish more people heard you
and this is why I'm
making the big to do here.
72 hours.
Now, all of you who I tell in your 20s
when you're doing dick shit nothing,
with your fucking life,
when I tell you to spend 2
hours a day on your couch
doing dick shit nothing,
and DM everybody you
admire and say to them,
"I've got fucking time,
you're busy as shit,
"I will fucking do anything.
"Eat shit for 15 hours a
week for free for you."
Once in a blue moon somebody says yes.
- [Eugene] Yeah.
- And that will change your life.
It happened to you.
Happened to D Rock.
Like happened to Andy, this is real.
- It's funny, but people
will pay for college,
but they don't want to not
get paid to go do work.
- How'd you two get your
job at Vaynor, originally?
- And how long were you here?
- Right, and then that led to this.
- That's right.
- Which is fitting you perfectly, right?
- Absolutely.
- Like I don't, I just wish fucking,
and you, how'd you get it?
- I just, you know,
it's just so real to me.
It's like I look at all of you like,
you know, like you better
be fucking listening.
And everybody who's listening right now,
you've got to just ask.
- [Eugene] Yeah.
- You just got to ask.
And you just have to
have something to offer.
And when you're a youngster,
like all of you were,
it's like, you have nothing to offer,
but your fucking grind.
- But that's the funny
thing, because when people go
for a job interview they're gonna be like,
how much are you going to pay me?
What are you gonna do for my future?
And that's where they've got it backwards.
They actually have to say,
"This is what I can do for you.
"And for that you should pay me something.
"But for now, I can do this for you,
"allow me to help you."
- Dude I swear on everything.
- And that's like a miss.
- People think I'm a
dick, I'm telling you,
I genuinely believe the people
in the top of their crafts
are gonna get people offering them to pay,
once people start putting
all these pieces together.
- Yeah absolutely, I mean look.
College, $30,000, $40,000 a year.
Your first business that you start,
you can make a $200,000 mistake
(snaps fingers) before you sneeze.
- I don't like giving people daps.
I'm telling you right
now, I'd have a tough time
saying no, to work for Jeff
Bezos for a month for free.
Right now, at the height--
- If you could stand next to Jeff Bezos
I would take that job right now, too.
I would love to, I'd love
to see the game he plays
'cause it's a game I--
- I need a fucking hour.
(Eugene chuckles)
Like I'll do it for a
month, because I committed.
(everyone laughs)
But like,
I need a fucking hour.
And I just wish more people,
let's get phone numbers.
So like, man, I'm sorry
to stop you in your story,
but fuck man!
- [Eugene] Let me say this.
- Knock yourself out.
- Digital marketing.
I didn't know a goddam thing
about digital marketing
two years ago.
We go to open Rumble.
We don't use digital marketing in Catch
in a traditional sense.
- Right, yup, yup.
- I don't know the cost proposition.
I don't know anything about retargeting,
all that stuff you know about.
Chris, who's the guy who runs
all of our digital marketing,
I meet him,
and two months later I
am speaking on a level
as good as my friends who
run advertising agencies.
And I just needed to be next to him.
And he needed to learn about brand,
which is what I do, the
authentic, the real.
And I needed to learn about what he did.
And together, that's what
made Rumble super successful,
but not one without the other.
But if I didn't have a guy like that.
- Math and art.
- I'd be structuring culture,
that's the way I look at it.
- It's all the same shit,
gray and black and white.
Fucking ditta, and fucking,
it's all the same shit!
- Yeah.
- It's the ying and yang,
in balance, in harmony.
- That's right.
- And everybody thinks
it's one or the other.
- And if he won because
he learned something,
I won, because I learned something.
And that's the other thing,
young people need to realize
it has to go both ways.
It has to be symbiotic.
It has to work.
- It's just, you know, like
you were saying earlier,
just like oh right like
you've been hanging out
with a bunch of the people on the team.
You're like, oh right
there's work in between.
- Yeah.
- People getting
confused by Instagram.
- [Eugene] Yeah.
- They see the fucking
blow up swans and the rose
and fucking Coachella.
And they just think like,
like most people aren't trust fund babies.
- That's right and they
forgot because 2007
wasn't too long ago.
And then 2008, all those jobs disappeared.
- I can't wait.
- And people had to reset.
I can't wait for it reset.
- Me too!
- 'Cause then people are gonna
get real jobs again.
But, it's interesting because
now you have all these
start ups with these big budgets,
and they're paying people this big money.
That's not gonna last.
And people are gonna
have to get real jobs.
Ask everybody where the A and R people are
from 20 years ago that
with an artist 25 deep.
They're gone.
- The amount of 49 year olds right now
that are executives in big companies
who can tell you at 22,
you know, they were worth
eight million dollars
on paper, is unlimited.
- [Eugene] Yeah.
- People just don't do their history.
- [Eugene] No.
- There's a very big
reason why my report card's
Ds and Fs, except for one class.
(Eugene laughs)
History.
- [Eugene] That's funny.
- It really, really matters.
- It matters.
And it's very interesting
to understand that
if you pay attention to the
people that do the work,
and then the people who don't do the work,
the history lesson will repeat itself,
and repeat itself,
- over and over,
- and repeat itself.
- and over.
- It's super simple.
I used to, people like philosophy
class, I didn't get it.
Now I find philosophy super interesting,
because the strategies
and the principles of it
are the same, super interesting.
- So what's on your mind these days?
Like knowing this is an
entrepreneurial audience,
like what, like what are you about now?
Like how are you thinking about,
you know you're scaling
these two companies.
- Yeah, I'm trying to keep
it real, quite honest.
I'm trying to keep it real
in a very unreal world.
I'm trying to match authentic experiences
in a place where people are trying to do
a lot of unauthentic things.
You got these micro
influencers, and this person
and that person.
Doing all these things,
and none of it are real.
And I'm trying to just do honest work.
I'm trying to do honest work,
I'm trying to do it in a creative way.
And it's very hard,
it was very--
- How was the Vegas opening?
I know that was recent for Catch.
- The Vegas opening was awesome.
You know it was really great.
And by the way, Randy
Gerber, who I worked for,
15 years ago, he owns
Casamigos tequila now.
Did fantastically well.
And,
you know from those relationships he did
his opening party with us.
So himself, George
Clooney, Cindy Crawford.
And that's a real honor.
You're 40 years old,
you worked for this guy
16, 17 years ago and for
him to throw his event.
- Which is a big event, right?
The Halloween thing?
- It's a big event, yeah.
It's was the whole thing,
it was 1,000 people,
it was they flew in on a private airplane,
they did a massive promotion around it.
And that's just priceless.
And those are the moments
when you pinch yourself
for a minute.
But you got to remember
like those are just moments,
just like every time I've ever gotten
something cool in the press,
I don't believe it on the really like
oh you're the best thing
that every happened.
Just like I won't believe
that I'm the worst thing
that ever happened.
I really try to,
- [Gary] Stay in the middle.
- stick it in the middle,
because if you did,
I dare you to get one of these
guys in this office to do
a New York Post, the hottest next this.
And go after 12 months
and see if it even exists.
It's probably a 90 to
one a failure to success.
So you really I think people,
if they're thinking about
keeping their success going,
be authentic, stay real.
- That's funny.
My brother and I have this sports agency,
and keep telling him,
the day you got drafted is the
day the work actually starts.
Everybody thinks, it's like BC funding.
Everybody used, there's
this great clip of me
on the internet, where I was
on this like Bloomberg show,
it was about like funding.
And every company got funding,
and the crowd's cheering.
- Oh yeah.
- You remember this?
And the one company goes,
"We didn't get funding.
"We just decided to make like a business
"and we're getting paid."
And the audience is dead silent.
I loose my shit.
I'm like, "See this is why
everything's fucked up."
I didn't say, I had to be--
- Be nicer than that.
(staff members laughing)
- Remember?
- [Andy] That's from
Damon when you went to
Damon John's talk.
- Yeah I brought up that story.
But like that clip is a
Bloomberg like tech stars show.
That's what it's from, Andy.
- Bloomberg.
- Remember, and I was pissed.
Like everyone celebrates the wrong shit.
We raised eight million
dollars, celebration!
No mother fucker!
You just gave up a big
chunk of your business
and now you have to execute.
- Yeah and now the--
- I just got, I got drafted!
I'm like, cool, but now
you have to actually play.
(staff members chuckle)
- Yeah.
- And like almost
everybody doesn't make it.
- [Eugene] And that's interesting.
- I know.
Page Six just said, there it is.
(laughter on recording)
- [Gary On Recording] You're
chunking your business!
(women laughing)
You just--
- I'm pissed.
- [Interviewer] Balancing is
a fundraising and building.
(people on recording crosstalk)
- [Gary On Recording]
You know I'm concerned
a little bit with the culture
of celebrating the fund raise.
You know my dad taught me
that when you borrow money,
it's the worst day of your life.
So, I'm very interested
in the entrepreneurs,
I'd like, you know we
didn't clap for Red Rover
because they didn't raise
six trillion dollars.
But I was sitting here like, good stuff.
I just filtered myself.
(everyone laughs)
- So like yeah you know?
- One meal at a time, one class at a time.
- We get the Post, Page Six
saying, you're the hottest,
you've watched over 20 years,
that place not around 12 months later.
- Doesn't happen and when you raise money,
and that's the other
thing everyone's like--
- Andy let's get a phone call.
Go ahead, keep going Eugene.
- You understand when you raise money
and you think you've done it,
no you just got started, and now you have
a much higher opportunity of failure,
than you did five minutes ago.
- And you have other voices!
- That's right.
- You got to answer to
Lambert or whatever, you know.
It's real!
- It's real.
It's not real if you do great.
If you do great, it's all roses.
(phone ringing)
- Who's this?
- [Andy] West Fields, North Carolina.
- West Fields the name?
(phone rings)
- [Andy] His name's West.
- [West] This is West.
- West, this is Gary Vaynorchuk.
- [West] Hey Gary, how are you?
- Very good, say hello to Eugene.
- [West] Hey Eugene, how's it going, man?
- Very well, my man, nice
to meet you, how are you?
- [West] Doing well, doing well.
- What is your question, my guy?
- [West] So, pretty straight forward.
I basically started an
event rental company,
basically doing like bounce
houses, tables, chairs,
water slides, Slip and Slides.
All the fun stuff about
a year and half ago.
And it really kind of ramped up.
Like it started it was
like, oh let's just kind of
make a couple extra hundred bucks.
And now like we're getting
pretty close to six figures.
So, but I'm starting
to get some competition
in the area that has basically
popped up out of nowhere,
copying my pricing, buying
the exact same units I have,
and copying all my social media stuff
that I'm throwing out there.
So, I wanted just some
advice on basically,
you know how to keep
crushing it, but also,
not to really care that that competition's
kind of popping up and
copying everything I'm doing.
- Dude, West you're fucking set!
Anytime somebody's copying
you, you have the leverage.
Everybody cries, I love when people,
people only copy me,
'cause I give away all my shit for free.
I vlog all day, live stream all day,
give away all my advice all day.
It's mainly 'cause I
want people copying me.
If somebody's copying
you, you fucking won.
The problem is, you can't
rest on your fucking laurels.
And if you're thinking
that somebody's copying you
is fucking you up, you're
starting to rest, my man.
- You just got to make sure
you're not a one trick,
you gotta make sure you're
not a one trick pony.
If you're doing something
and that's the only thing
you can do, and some dude follows you,
then you're not that great.
- Then you deserve to lose, dick!
(Eugene laughs)
You know what I mean?
Like that's the punchline.
- [West] Right.
- Like if you're so copyable,
that if somebody copies it,
that it fucks up your game,
you deserve to lose, that's
actually how it plays out.
- Elevate or die, elevate or die.
- [West] Absolutely.
- And West, I'll tell
you the thing is is like,
you know you capture something, right?
Like I mean, back to what we
were talking about earlier.
Somebody opens a big time big restaurant
in the Meat Packing
District, they're crushing,
what do you think happens next?!
- That's right.
- Somebody else fucking buys
another building and they open one!
If that person starts
crying that that happened,
they always lose, I see this every day.
Like nothing is ownable.
I love when people hit me
up on social, or email,
or DM, they're like, "Yo!
"I need to copyright my idea.
"Or I need to trademark my idea."
I'm like, "Mother fucker,
you think this is 1984?!"
That shit's over!
This is about execution!
There's no fucking original ideas!
And oh by the way bro,
you didn't fucking invent rentals
and fucking Slip and Slides either.
- [West] Oh absolutely not!
- So stop, go ahead.
(West audio cuts out)
- [West] I think I've seen that this year.
And we really got rejuvenated
this year to really start
branching into other areas
that none of the competition
in my area are going.
To keep it fresh and to really start to,
you know give offerings that you know hey,
- That's it.
- it's brand new fresh
- [West] to the area that, you know hey,
they're gonna have to
come along and copy those
if they want them.
- And I'll tell you,
- Absolutely, just fresh.
- I'll tell you what runs through my mind.
Success often leads to complacency.
Right?
- Absolutely.
- And I think what you just
went through a cycle of,
is like when I heard that you just said,
we got rejuvenated,
you got rejuvenated because
competition rejuvenated you,
not you rejuvenated yourself.
And that's okay, but that's
a lesson you need to learn.
Does that make sense?
- [West] Absolutely, 100%.
- And I would just add this.
I think about, if you think
about your competition,
you think too much about them,
it's like a pick pocketer
tapping you on the shoulder.
You look to your left and they're stealing
your wallet to the right.
Focus on your own wallet,
focus on your own stuff,
and don't allow yourself
to get pick pocketed
by some dude tapping you on the shoulder.
Stay focused on your stuff.
And like Gary said, don't get distracted.
Stay true to what you're doing
and you're gonna be great.
- West, the worst thing
going on in my life right now
is that people think I know who they are.
- [West] Right.
- Like I'm out and about, right,
and I'm at the Superbowl,
I'll be in Charlotte
for the NBA All-Star, I'll go to Eugene's,
very trendy places, and there's
very special people there.
And I'm being introduced
and people are starting
to know who I am because
of what's happening
in my life, and I'm
devas, this is not a joke.
This is the single thing I
stress about on Earth right now,
I spend no time,
not a minute, knowing what
anybody on Earth is doing
except my audience responding to my shit.
Thus, when I'm out in public,
and they're like, "Hey Gary,
you know Johnny MaGoo!"
And I'm like, "Fuck!"
Like clearly everyone
knows who Johnny MaGoo is.
I don't want to come off as
like egotistical and a dick.
So I'm like, and I don't
want to come off and be like,
"Yeah," but then be inauthentic.
Literally this is not a joke, bro.
The number one anxiety I have right now,
is I almost don't know
who anybody is on Earth.
Because I'm so in my own shit.
And I'm telling you right now,
more people need to do that.
Because if you're worried
about anybody else,
that's a minute that you're
taking away from your customer.
Instead of like looking at
them copying your social,
call every customer that you've ever had
and say thank you and ask
them if they need anything.
- [West] Absolutely.
- Cool, good luck bro.
- Absolutely.
- Thank you man.
Okay, let's do another
one, the energy is perfect.
Eugene on that note,
let's talk about Rumble for a minute.
- All right.
- How is the boxing?
One thing I'm curious about,
how are you thinking about this?
You're too smart to not know this truth.
Right now in America,
over the last half decade
it's been very clear
that the exercise trends
have been popping, and
then fading pretty quickly.
Cycles, like have been going fast.
- [Eugene] Yeah.
- How do you think about that
when you think about Rumble,
in the fact that whether
it's Orange Theory,
or Soul Cycle, or you know?
Clear, I just know you enough
even in the limited time,
you have to be thinking about like okay,
how do I build something
that's a marathon run,
- That's right.
- that isn't just playing
on this trend--
- It's not a fad, it's iconic.
- [Gary] That's right.
- So you got to do iconic type shit.
You got to do stuff that
is better every single day,
and day in and day out.
I will say this though.
- [Gary] Please.
- Sushi has been around
for hundreds of years.
It used to be in a shitty little room,
with a shitty little guy
and you didn't see anything.
All of a sudden place like Nobu,
put some house music, some cool lighting,
and some sauces on the stuff
and rejuvenates the brand.
But the authenticity of
sushi was always there.
Boxing--
- I'm a buyer.
You sold me, you sold me!
- Boxing, same shit.
It's been around
- Sold!
- for hundreds of years!
African American, white
people, Irish people,
rich people, poor people.
- Sold me.
- It shifts, UFC, it
goes to something else.
It's always gonna be there
and more importantly,
it's a damn good time,
it's a damn good workout
and it works.
- Sold me.
- All right.
- I believe you.
(Gary whispers low)
(phone rings)
There is that.
Who's this?
- [Andy] Christine.
- Christine?
- [Christine] It's Christine.
- Christine, it's Gary
Vaynorchuk, I'm on with Eugene.
Please say hello.
- Awesome!
- [Christine] Hi Gary, how are you?
- I'm super well, say hello to Eugene.
- [Christine] Hey Eugene, how are you?
- Good how are you?
What's going on?
- I am awesome!
- [Christine] I'm so
stoked you guys called me.
Gary can I please fly to
New York and buy you lunch?
- No.
- One time.
(Eugene laughs)
- [Christine] Please?!
- No, I mean, I'm fucking busy!
Like lunch takes time!
- Oh my gosh!
- [Christine] You're fucking busy?!
I'm fucking busy, okay let me lay down
for you guys a real question.
- I didn't ask you,
you asked me, Christine!
- [Christine] (laughs)
Please, please, please?!
- Ask your, let's see how
good your question is.
- [Christine] How good my
question is, okay listen.
Let me lay this down.
I found you Gary on
Facebook like two years ago,
you were standing in front of a dumpster
telling us stories about
how other people's opinions
are trash, they're fucking trash!
- Yes.
- [Christine] Let me tell you,
that changed my life, Gary.
You changed my life with that statement.
And I just want to thank you. (cries)
Because you changed my life.
I started my business 18 months ago.
Five-O Donut Co on Instagram.
If you would follow me, I would die.
- I'm gonna follow you right now,
you got me hyped, what is it?
- [Christine] I'm a little,
it's a little cop logo
holding a donut, it's genius right?
So, I started my little
donut shop 18 months ago.
I'm grossing over 500K a year.
- Wow!
- I just opened
my second store.
- Hold on, hold on you're firing me up!
(Christina laughs)
Because I want, I like what's
going on with Justin's face.
Hold on, hold on.
18 months ago I'm on the,
I'll never forget that,
I was on a flight, I read
something as we were landing
that pissed me off like no business.
I ran off the plane.
I was pissed because D Rock
was taking a few minutes
to get off the plane, 'cause
- Yup.
- I could feel my energy
of like my anger,
excitement, need to talk,
- [Christine] Yeah.
- fading, so like we couldn't wait,
so I was like fuck it,
let's just do it in front
of this dumpster.
- [Christine] Yes!
- It's amazing how truth always wins.
So you see that video,
it changes your mindset
and allows you to start a
business, is that what happened?
- [Christine] Yeah, because,
people I've owned bakeries
in Sarasota for a long time,
I'm in Sarasota, Florida and I was like,
the last caller called in.
Other people always starting stuff up,
everybody's copying your business.
So I wanted to do something
that would take off,
that would fucking light and take off,
and that's what I needed.
And that's what I need for my life.
And so I saw that video.
And there's this guy, I
call him a keyboard warrior
here in town, and he was
writing shit about me online,
telling everybody I was a hack.
And it pissed me off!
And so I saw your video and that was it.
That was my mindset for
the past 18 months is that,
those people are trash, but
then you've been preaching
lately about listening to your customers.
And how important their opinions are.
And if they're telling
you that you're doing
a shitty job, so I walk a fine balance
between those two strings of your opinion.
- By the way, that is
the contradiction, right?
- [Christine] Yes!
- You know everybody always
says to me like Gary,
there's that classic line, like
if I listen to my customers
I would have made faster
horses and not made a car.
But then there's like tone deaf.
That's exactly right,
it's in that balance.
But let me tell you one thing.
Those keyboard warriors,
as we like to call them,
they're not your fucking customers.
- No.
- They're people that are pain
they're people that are hurting inside.
And the only outlet that they understand
is trying to drag somebody
into their misery.
- [Christine] And you're,
exactly and you know what else
they are, they're people
that are sitting on the
fucking sidelines, because
they don't have the balls
to jump in the game!
- But I'll say this.
- That's what.
- But I'll say this Christine,
(crosstalk and laughter)
but I'll say this.
One of the reasons why I'm
so happy is I don't have
that same level of anger that
you're spitting right now,
which I love, by the way.
I love it, because it's a motivator.
Believe it or not, and
it's fun to be sipping it,
wait a minute!
I have a funny feeling you
did not buy Empathy Wines.
Tell the truth right now!
If you lie, you will die.
Did you order Empathy Wines?
- [Christine] Did I what?
- Did you order Empathy Wines?
Did you go to empathywines.com
and order a subscription?
Do not lie.
- No, are you kidding me?!
I'm a single mom, yo!
I've got to put
clothes on my kids!
- You're doing $500,000
in fucking revenue!
(Christine yelling)
- Can I get 83 fuckin dollars!
Can I get $83.00!
- I've got kids,
- [Christine] My kids'
dad will give me shit!
I got to pay for all my money,
are you kidding me?!
- Get the fuck out of here!
- I didn't. (laughs)
- You buy me!
If you don't order Empathy Wines,
there's no prayer for lunch!
- [Christine] Okay, I will
go buy it, okay listen.
I will go buy it on Wednesday,
if you let me buy you lunch.
- Nope, but.
We're gonna start with,
- Let's do it.
- we're gonna start with this train.
You're gonna buy Empathy--
- I'll bring you donuts.
- Well I do like donuts.
- I do like donuts, but at
my heaviest this morning
I tipped it, like I got
to fucking get focused.
I'm fasting today
with a little bit of wine.
- Oh my god.
- Listen to me.
- Okay.
- You need to order
Empathy Wines, I'll give you a follow,
we'll start building
our relationship slowly.
- [Christine] Sounds good.
- Good, all right
what's you're question?
- I like to take it slow,
- [Christine] I like to take it slow,
even though your (voice fades away).
So I like to (audio fades),
just like business relationships
I like to (voice fuzzy), you know
get my toe in the water first.
- What can we answer for you?
- [Christine] Awesome, so scalable growth.
Franchising or company owned stores?
- Great question.
- I've had people coming at me
- [Christine] right and left with offers.
- What's the name of, what's
the name of the company?
'Cause I want to make
sure everybody hears it.
Five-O Donut Co in Sarasota, Florida.
- Five-O Donut Co, that's
fucking fresh, actually.
It won us all over, everyone's like yay.
- [Christine] Go look, I've got outlines
of like chalk, people on
the floor holding a donut.
I've got a mug shot
wall with a photo booth,
you can come in and take
your mug shot and photo booth
and send it out on your
Instagram, your Facebook.
So basically my customers are creating ads
for me every time they
walk through the door.
I've got little cop siren
lights all over the place.
- How many?
- We've got donuts--
- And you have what, one location?
- [Christine] Two locations, currently.
- Both in Florida?
- [Christine] Yeah, I opened
my first location one year,
I opened my first location
at the end of May 2017,
and then Summer of 2018, a year later,
I opened my second location.
- Nick Deo just followed you.
(everyone laughs)
I'm looking at your, yeah.
- [Christine] Yeah that's on my Insta.
We're doing donut bouquets--
- You guys are doing
real good product porn.
It's really good.
- Yeah.
- What's the debate between
franchising and owner/operator?
What are you trying to figure out?
- [Christine] (sighs) I'm
just trying to figure out
the best way to scale growth,
for me, because--
- They both work, by the way.
They both like,
- They both work?
- This is historically correct.
They both work, it becomes
a self awareness game.
- Of how dope you are.
- Okay.
- You have to understand how dope you are,
or you have to understand
what are you--
- What you like?
- Yeah.
- What you like.
Like I'll be honest with you.
Like I'm weirdly like,
I'm going from not wanting
to have lunch with you,
to wanting to be your business partner.
Like you better stay on the phone here.
I'm like looking at Phil, I might send,
Phil Toronto might be coming
to Florida to see you.
- [Christine] Gary can I tell
you, if you check your DM,
I sent you a DM saying, Gary
please be our business partner.
(Christine laughs)
- I'll be honest with you,
like I actually--
- Let me tell you,
- I'm obsessed with donuts.
- like my--
What's that?
- When's the last time
you had a donut?
- No, no, I don't have,
like I'll eat, no, no,
(everyone laughs)
no, Eugene, Eugene!
- Please, please!
- No, no, no, I had a muff--
- You eat sushimi, you eat healthy,
I've seen it.
- I do, but when I go,
when I am willing to escape,
it is always baked goods.
- [Eugene] Okay.
- Yeah.
- Like baked goods are always
when I want to escape.
- Yeah.
- And like I had a muffin
in LA like two days ago,
and it was fucking amazing!
- I've never seen Gary
eat anything other than
healthy food every single time.
- Well 'cause you have
really good food at Catch.
- Yes.
- By the way, anybody watching
you have to go to Catch.
It's in every fucking location.
- You don't have to, but if
you want to, you should--
- No, no you can't say that,
I can.
- Go to Five-O Donut Co!
- [Christine] Come on!
- All right why don't we do this?
I want to have a business
meeting with you at Catch
with Phil Toronto in the next 60 days.
45 minutes, meet you and
Phil Toronto at Catch.
One objective, possibly
being business partners.
- [Christine] Amazing.
- Done.
- I would totally be down.
- [Christine] Gothca, I got to go,
I'll send you an email right now.
And I'm going to buy my
wine after I get home
from the grocery store.
- You better, or that meeting's
not gonna happen, see you.
All right Eugene.
- What's happening?
(everyone laughs loudly)
- I feel good about her.
I think she may have something.
- She may.
- Five-O Donut Co.
- I don't get the idea of
like dead people though
and mugs shots on the floor.
- Who gives a fuck?!
I don't get the idea of like
supermodels boxing, you fucking hacked it.
- Hey, I follow Gizelle, I don't have to
make that rule up.
- All right Eugene,
we've got a few minutes,
'cause I see Tyler getting antsy.
- I could see him through the mirror.
- He's antsy.
- He's stressed.
- I want to make sure we
get across anything that you
kind of, you thought about this.
Like is there anything
that is on your mind,
anything you want to share?
Anything we didn't talk about?
- No, I'm look I'm excited
to be here.
I love working with young people.
By the way the two
people that used to work
at your office that work here,
I called you and I said, "Look,
I need some young hustlers
"and I want people with growth."
And you handed me two guys.
- And by the way on that
note, I apologize Eugene,
for everybody watching,
if you own a business, if
you're running a company,
one thing I always say, like obviously
I always want to keep everybody.
However, you have, if you own a business,
if you actually want to
bring value to people,
you have to watch the
people that work for you.
There are times when it's,
when I look and it's obvious to me
that different people
need different jerseys
than the one they
currently have in my place
where I know they can shine.
Plus it's moments in time.
I'll be very honest with you.
Both of the guys, I'll
look them dead in the face,
if they came to Vaynor in 2009,
it would have been different.
- [Eugene] Yeah.
- But when they were in
the system at that time,
through the serendipity,
it's fucking serendipity!
I think way too many people
are selfish with talent, right?
And then more importantly,
like don't realize
how the world works.
Like this couldn't make me feel better.
- I agree.
And I got to say this,
it's hard to find talent.
So if I'm sitting here talking
about Catch and Rumble,
they're both super exciting brands.
I'm just creating
experiences, quite honestly.
So when people ask, how do I
do better than the next guy?
I don't know.
I can buy the same tuna that you can buy.
I can buy the same vodka that you can buy.
I could buy the same
wine that you can buy.
It's got to be everything else.
So it's always the intangible things.
- But it's P and P, right?
It's patience and practicality.
You have both those things, Eugene.
- Look, what I have is patience,
but what I'm challenged by is that I think
every day is my last.
And that is something from being a kid,
and that's a problematic thing in even
how successful you are,
you always think that every
day's your birthday party.
And when I walk into Catch,
I think every day's my birthday party,
I don't think anyone's coming.
So I get every morning with
that stress on my back.
And I try to find that sense of urgency
in young people, can not.
- I think being patient
and lacking entitlement
is very easy to balance both.
- You can't have entitlement in
- No shit.
- the business that you do.
You absolutely have to realize that--
- If you have customers,
you can't have entitlement.
- Absolutely.
- That's the singular mistake I see.
- Here's what I realized.
You walk into Catch, I don't wait for you
to come say hello to me if
I'm sitting at the table,
I jump the fuck up and I go to you
to say hi to your table.
And now people who think they ever get to
an ownership position,
think life gets easier.
I don't understand that, why they think
they're gonna have less problems
when they become successful.
- You work for them.
- I work for everybody.
- 100,000%!
The only people I don't
work for is my parents,
'cause they love me no matter what.
Beyond that, like I got to perform.
And I got to earn.
And I know that going into it.
Look I've had some amazing
years in the success of Catch,
and the success of Rumble,
but we've had some bad years.
We've closed some places.
I'm not ashamed to talk about that stuff,
by the way.
- It's great!
I love it when business fail!
- Those failure, (chuckles)
those failures--
- I hope Empathy fails
so Troutie and they can get real jobs!
(Eugene laughs)
Like I'm pumped!
Like I'm, I love losing!
It's part of the equation.
You know what's--
- It's not losing though.
- Of course it's--
- It's not real losing.
- But, it is losing, except you're willing
to learn from that loss.
- That's right.
- It's losing!
A business going out
of business is losing.
- That's right.
It's not growth.
- What you're saying is,
what you're saying is, in the
macro it doesn't have to be,
it's not the end.
- No, and a lot of times you think it is.
So for anybody who's ever lost,
it's not real loss.
- You know where you just went
that I keep thinking about
all the time, something I've
been thinking a ton, sports.
Right, Kobie Bryant,
Paul Pierce, who I hate.
You know, anybody.
- He's so great, I love--
- Anybody, whoever, anybody.
Any great athlete in any sport, right?
Mariano Rivera, Darrelle
Revis, I'll use like,
nonetheless, whatever, ready?
Here's how sports works.
You go into the league, right?
It's completely based on
merit, if you're good enough,
19, 20, if you're good
enough, you're good enough.
You play your whole career,
you become a fucking legend.
You are a hall of famer.
You're towards the end of your career, 34,
young by the way, 35, 37.
Nobody on the field
cares that you're going
to the hall of fame.
Actually let's use boxing.
Every great boxer, pretty
much except for Floyd
and a couple of other people,
get their fucking ass,
do you know who Muhammad Ali lost to?
Trevor Burbick.
Trevor Burbick is the last
person to beat Mohammad Ali.
Beat his ass.
Not Larry Holmes like everybody thinks,
'cause they're not educated.
- Beat his ass?
- Trevor Burbick,
beat the fuck out of Mohammad Ali, right?
You know why?
'Cause in sports you get to see it happen.
Which is you're only as
good as your last at bat.
- That's right.
- In business, for some reason
back to your point, people get
big, they had a great career.
And for some reason those mother fuckers,
think they get to relax, but the market,
the customer,
they're Trevor Burbick.
It wasn't Trevor Burbick's job.
And I think he went in
the Bahamas, look it up,
I think it was somewhere outside the US,
I think it's Bahamas.
It wasn't Trevor Burbick's
job in 1982, 1983.
- [Andy] He knocked out Tyson.
- No, no Mike Tyson
knocked out Trevor Burbick.
Trevor Burbick beat Mohammad Ali,
go look at Mohammad Ali's career.
Google Mohammad Ali's last--
- Let's assume it's a fact.
- It is a fucking fact.
(Eugene laughs)
It wasn't Trevor Burbick's job
to go into that ring and
say, "Mohammad Ali you're
"a legend, let me lay down for you."
He beat his fucking ass, right?
- [Andy] Unanimous
decision, Mohammad was 39,
Burbeck was 27.
- Right!
- Because Mohammad Ali needs to know,
he needs to get into a different ring.
- Correct.
- He needs to take
a different career.
- And I have no idea why
all these entrepreneurs
running around here build a big business,
and then think they can
rest on their laurel.
Because a young lion is
coming to take your shit.
- That's right.
It's funny people want
only to get regular jobs,
they have a structure and now that's like
poo-pooed as a bad thing.
But man it's hard, push
yourself every day.
Get up in the morning and say,
if you don't have to be at
work at 9:00 a.m., do you go?
Do you go to lunch a little longer?
Do you hang out a little longer?
And then how much money can
you lose in five minutes?
- Andy and I were in LA
on business the other day.
And after a meeting,
that lasted 20 minutes,
which I dictated 19 of,
the other crew went to lunch
for an hour and a half.
And we went back to our
car to our next meeting,
and I was making fun of it.
And Andy just lives right here.
And it was like funny, like he was like,
"Yeah I don't even know what
the real world looks like."
Like that's exactly right.
- LA, by the way is a meeting pre-lunch
and a meeting post lunch
and that's about it.
And that's it, two meetings in the day,
and lunch in between to break
it up before you end the day.
And that's the LA life, but again,
entrepreneurship has this
sexy vocabulary to it.
- Sucks (drowned out).
- Go do it, go do it.
- Every single person here
isn't the last line of defense.
Last line of defense sucks.
There's nobody else to--
- Have great partners, that's
what I would say to anybody,
have great partners.
- What's your question of the day?
- I wrote I down
- I know you did.
- so I wouldn't mess it up.
What's the one business you believe
can be elevated by an experience?
Something whack, something
that needs to be disrupted.
What's something that
people do every single day
that needs to be disrupted?
I want to know, 'cause I want to do it.
- I love it.
- I want to do it.
- Thanks for being on brother.
Love you man.
- Appreciate it,
thank you so much for your time.
Great to see all you young people,
make me look old and feel old.
You all got great hair, by the way.
Really.
(staff members laugh)
- Thanks for being on.
- Thank you appreciate it.
- You guys keep watching.
Hey guys, thank you so much for watching
my video on YouTube.
I wanted to jump in here at the end,
because I'm working on a
ridiculously important project
for me, and I have a funny
feeling you can help.
If you drink wine at all,
or know anybody that drinks
wine at all, please go to
empathywines.com right now
and sign up for a subscription.
Whether it's a three pack,
whether it's a six pack,
or whether it's a whole
case of each for the year.
If you drink 36 bottles of wine a year,
or give away 36 bottles of wine a year,
please sign up for Club Empathy.
This project means the world to me.
I could really use your support.
(upbeat digital hip hop
drum beats and music)